salut ça va
vous mangez ça
encore bien américain
tu vas bien Thierry bonsoir tu fais quoi
la communication
mon épouse Coralie
c'était arrivé près de chez moi
[Musique]
qui s'appelle TTBM il paraît que ça veut
dire très bien monté c'est un magasin
bon à tout à l'heure
la barrière
[Musique]
je comprends la caméra sur ses yeux
on peut avoir du ketchup
vous nous en apportez et puis du
champagne
vous avez du champagne californien du
champagne californien
on va avoir du ketchup et du champagne
californien
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui aimait bien les news
allez
vous étiez pas nombreux pour bien le
dire quand même fallait le dire avant il
fallait le dire
c'est arrivé près de chez vous tu sais
que ça nous a carrément collé au plafond
ce film quand même c'est vrai
de te rencontrer très heureux parce que
vraiment ça ne sertment j'ai pas fait
fortune dans la flagornerie
mais je trouve ça très bien
merci beaucoup voilà ça me fait très
plaisir
[Musique]
pour enfant et de la photo j'ai sorti
une école de communication et je n'ai
jamais si j'ai fait une exposition pour
les enfants pendant un an une exposition
pour apprendre les dangers de la
pollution
et puis quand elle s'est terminée
et puis quand c'était terminé c'est le
film est sorti à ce moment-là
et le film il a marché ou pas marché
il a bien marché parce qu'on ne
s'attendait pas du tout à ce
successionnaire je peux te tutoyer tu
peux me tutoyer
le Canadien
d'avoir les Belges et les Canadiens
parce que on sait plus quoi faire tu
vois heureusement il y a des comics
belges et chanteur Canadiens ça aide
c'est cool la tête comme ça
alors qu'est-ce que tu fais sur scène
je joue un
un homme qui a qui attend vainement sa
femme dans un café ouais et qui souffre
entre autres de ne pas être reconnu dans
son métier et nous savons tous ceux que
c'est mais en plus ils ouvrent davantage
de savoir que sa femme elle est reconnue
dans ce qu'elle fait alors que pour lui
elle fait quelque chose de tout à fait
idiot
ça veut dire qu'elle fait enregistrer
une chanson idiote c'est Mélissa c'est
ça c'est Mélissa et il souffre vous
savez c'est tout la souffrance
mais pourquoi
c'est pas Mélissa toi tu es Coralie
c'est pas inspiré de Coralie cette
histoire
oh bien mieux bien mieux elle n'a pas
besoin de chanter
[Musique]
c'est quand même marrant qu'à Paris on
est autant de mal à trouver du champagne
California je peux te prendre une
cigarette merci
c'était vraiment intéressant coraliement
je vais qu'est-ce que tu en fais
franchement
mais c'est pas grave non
je crois que c'est de ma faute
normalement je parle pas c'est pas
obligé de manger
franchement
la Belgique c'est vachement plus
américaine la France la Belgique est
plus americanisée que la France non non
un truc comme ça
non non non pas du tout non non la
Belgique c'est c'est bien belge quoi
c'est resté très français la Belgique
c'est bien mais
attention les mecs
je veux absolument que tu boives du
champagne californien attention
attention merci beaucoup
tiens
voilà attention vous êtes prêts
attention tout le monde est prêt
1 2 3
et bien c'est très bon c'est pas mal on
ne sait pas foutu de ta gueule non c'est
bon
champagne californien
[Musique]
français il est moins cher
parce que tout le monde
[Musique]
[Rires]